[Music]
like to ask you about GPA Stanford says
that there's no minimum GPA but can you
get in without low GPA I'd also like to
know how you evaluate GPAs and outside
of the US both of those questions come
up from applicants often as well again
the GPA is just one indicator but this
one is about a four year period of time
often a three or four period of time so
we we do look at that for us if you
think about the GPA we know that it's
going to vary by institution you know
the level of a GPA also even by major
sometimes I find that highly rigorous
quantitative majors or sometimes more
science oriented on average students
GPAs will be lower there so that's
something we're taking into
consideration in addition if you think
about international schools we don't
convert their their GPAs into u.s.
conversions we actually look at the
country and try to be familiar with
what's their educational system and
recognize that oftentimes international
GPAs are less inflated than u.s. GPAs
maybe so if all of that is for you to
realize that we're trying to do our best
to understand what it looks like in your
particular context that being said if
there's if you look at your transcript
and take it and look at it with fresh
eyes on an applicant and you see a point
in time a semester court or whatever it
was where you don't think it reflects
your true capabilities tell us about
that we have an additional information
section could have been health it could
have been a personal situation but we
want we're looking for reasons to admit
you not four reasons to deny so any
context that you can give us to help
understand you know what your ejector
has been will be really helpful that's
great I like the affirming of that too
or looking for reasons to admit it's not
to deny us exactly and no applicant is
going to be upstanding in every
dimension so you put your best foot
forward and know that those strengths
are the important things